Russia shares this big long border with
Finland and Finland just joined NATO the
Western military Alliance they're also
about to let American troops come to
Finland and Russia does not like this so
as a response they have been sending
migrants from like War zones that are
looking for Asylum and safety to this
border and they're putting them on
bicycles and they have nowhere to go but
into Finland now Russia knows that
Finland is required to let these Asylum
seekers in and the Hope here is that
this flood of migrants will create
Discord and Division within Finnish
society and will make them angry at this
decision to join NATO or to let us
troops in Putin is using these migrants
as a weapon in his hybrid Warfare
against the West so in response Finland
actually closed these land border
crossings and so now you have this
terrible situation of migrants just
sitting there not able to go anywhere in
these terrible conditions if you want to
better understand global politics follow
along for more